wenn sie für einen längeren zeitraum
bewegungslos sehen
zum beispiel aufgrund einer operation
krankheit schwangerschaft oder reise
besteht das risiko einer tiefen
venenthrombose tvt bei der sich in einer
tiefen venen des körpers und meistens im
bein ein blutgerinnsel bildet im
gegensatz zu arterien durch die das blut
aktiv durch den herzschlag gepumpt wird
transportieren wähnen das blut mit hilfe
von muskelkontraktionen durch bewegungen
und gehen venen haben außerdem klappen
die das blut daran hindern rückwärts zu
fließen und sich in den armen beinen zu
sammeln
wenn sie sich länger nicht bewegen
verlangsamt sich der venen kreislauf
dadurch können die gerinnungsfaktoren im
blut dazu führen dass sich im blut ein
gerinnsel
oder thrombus bildet
dieser zustand wird als tiefe
venenthrombose oder tvt bezeichnet
zu den häufigsten symptomen der tvt
gehören
schwellung des beins oder einer beinvene
schmerzen oder empfindlichkeit im
entsprechenden bereich erhöhte haut
wärme gerötete oder verfärbte haut
in einigen tvt fällen löst sich das
gerinnsel aus der tiefen venen und
geräten im blutstrom
das gerinnsel bewegt sich dabei aus den
tiefen beinvenen über die bauch venen
bis zum herz und lagert sich in der
lungenarterie oder deren verzweigungen
an wodurch es zu einer blockade des blut
stroms in die lungen kommt
dieser zustand der auch als
lungenembolie bezeichnet wird ist
außerordentlich gefährlich und kann
einen teil der lunge dauerhaft
beschädigen
je nach der größe des thrombus oder bei
mehreren gerinnseln kann eine
lungenembolie sogar tödlich sein
wenn sie symptome einer lungenembolie
bemerken sagen sie ihrem arzt oder einer
krankenschwester sofort bescheid
dazu gehören
im not
plötzliche stechende schmerzen im
brustkorb schwindelgefühl
schneller oder unregelmäßiger herzschlag
oder husten mit blutigem auswurf
der arzt ihre ärztin kann möglicherweise
folgendes anordnen um tiefe
venenthrombose oder lungenembolie zu
verhindern
gelegentliches gehen um eine blut-
ansammlung in den beinen zu vermeiden
tragen von kompressionsstrümpfen
einnahme von gerinnungshemmern